- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La parole est à monsieur
Jocelyn Dessigny.
- Jocelyn Dessigny:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
au ministre
de l'Economie,
des Finances
et de la Souveraineté
industrielle numérique.
Quand un groupe annonce
la fermeture d'une usine
dans l'Aisne,
c'est tout le département
qui souffre.
Tous ses habitants
sont fiers de produire
les biscuits
que l'on retrouve
dans les poches
des écoliers français
à l'heure du goûter.
Tout comme nos agriculteurs,
ils travaillent
pour nous nourrir
et ils demandent
à vivre de leur travail.
Sur les plateaux télé
et dans les journaux,
vous avancez fiers
pour vanter vos mérites
et annoncer vos chiffres
de soi-disant réindustrialisation
de la France.
En Provence,
c'est la réalité qui éclate
sous nos yeux.
Bien que créée
à Château-Thierry,
les capitaux seront
désormais fabriqués
en République tchèque.
Les sites industriels
ferment les uns
après les autres
sans que vous ne bougiez
le petit doigt.
Depuis une semaine,
ce sont des centaines
de familles
qui ne dorment plus,
parce qu'elles se demandent
comment elles vont payer
leurs factures et leur loyer,
alors que le prix
des factures d'électricité explose,
malgré vos belles promesses.
Depuis 10 ans,
les ouvriers
se sont adaptés,
ils ont augmenté
leur productivité et ils ont fait
preuve d'humilité.
C'est une qualité
qui vous manque
pour sauver notre patrimoine
industriel.
Comment comptez-vous
concrètement oeuvrer
pour sauver ces emplois?
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Monsieur le député,
je partage
votre inquiétude.
Je partage la douleur
de tous les salariés,
qui ont appris
il y a quelques jours
que l'usine allait fermer.
Cette usine comportait
1200 salariés,
il y a encore quelques années.
Elle en comporte 60, aujourd'hui.
Nous veillerons
au replacement de chacun
des salariés.
Nous demandons
à l'entreprise de faire
le nécessaire pour replacer
chaque salarié.
Je vous remercie
du travail
que vous allez engager
avec l'entreprise
et avec le maire
de Château-Thierry,
pour trouver un repreneur.
L'essentiel, pour moi,
aujourd'hui,
est qu'il y ait
une reprise industrielle
sur ce site et que ce site
ne ferme pas.
Pour le reste
et pour la politique industrielle
que nous menons,
je regarde les chiffres,
même si je le redis,
je vais me battre
pour le site industriel
de Château-Thierry.
Il n'empêche que,
dans un pays qui,
depuis 40 ans, a détruit 2
millions d'emplois industriels,
a fermé des milliers
de sites industriels,
nous en avons recréé
des centaines
sur notre pays.
Nous avons recréé 100.000
emplois industriels
pour la première fois
depuis une trentaine d'années.
Le département de l'Aisne
a pu en bénéficier.
C'est un département
dynamique,
qui a eu beaucoup
de créations d'entreprises.
Je vous propose
de nous mobiliser
tous ensemble
pour avoir une réindustrialisation
en bon ordre de ce site.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
merci, monsieur
le ministre.
Monsieur le député?
- Jocelyn Dessigny:
Vos belles promesses,
on sait où elles finissent.
Aujourd'hui,
ce sont des actes
que nous voulons.
Je vous invite
à vous joindre à moi
pour nous rendre ensemble
sur le site historique
de Belin, afin
de rencontrer le personnel
et la direction.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
Soumya Bourouaha.
- Soumya Bourouaha:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Je souhaite
tout d'abord associer
mon groupe à l'hommage
rendu aux Invalides
aux victimes du 7
octobre 2023 en Israël.
Il n'y a pas de mots
assez forts
pour qualifier
les crimes commis
par le Hamas.
Nous adressons
nos pensées aux victimes,
aux familles
et aux otages,
dont nous espérons
la libération rapide.
L'horreur de ces vies brisées
ne peut justifier
ce qu'il se passe
actuellement à Gaza.
Avec une délégation
de parlementaires
et d'élus locaux,
nous nous sommes rendus
à Rafah, à la frontière
avec l'Egypte.
Les témoignages
que nous avons entendus
sont édifiants.
A l'hôpital, j'ai échangé
avec des mères
et des enfants
qui nous ont raconté comment
ils ont marché
durant des jours
pour se rendre
à la frontière égyptienne
pour se faire soigner.
Raphaël Pitti
raconte le sort
de ces civils,
qui n'ont plus d'endroit
pour se faire soigner.
La bande de Gaza
est un champ de ruines,
où la population vit recluse
sur 34 kilomètres carrés.
Il n'y a pas que les bombes
qui tuent,
il y a aussi la pénurie
de médicaments,
de nourriture et d'eau.
Les Gazaouis sont entassés
dans le seul hôpital
en service et qui est au bord
de l'effondrement.
La France doit
préserver ses aides
à la seule organisation présente
qui apporte son aide aux civils.
Comment se satisfaire
de cette aide minime,
si elle n'arrive même pas à parvenir
jusqu'aux Gazaouis?
Quelles sont les actions
que notre démocratie met
en oeuvre pour obtenir
un cessez-le-feu immédiat
et permanent?
- Stéphane Séjourné:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Madame la députée,
merci
pour votre question.
Au vu des tensions
de la situation humanitaire
que vous évoquez,
et du risque
pour la sécurité
au Proche-Orient,
je me suis rendu,
ces derniers jours,
en Egypte, en Jordanie,
en Israël,
en Palestine et au Liban.
La France peut
être fière
d'être le pays
européen le plus actif
sur le terrain
en partenariat
avec les pays arabes de la région.
Je pense notamment
à l'Egypte
et à la Jordanie.
Vous connaissez
la position de la France.
Nous l'exposons ici,
depuis le début
de ce conflit:
condamnation des actes terroristes
du Hamas et demande
de libération immédiate
des otages, soutien
humanitaire et appel
à un arrêt des combats,
pour mettre fin
aux souffrances des civils à Gaza.
Il y a aussi la nécessité d'une
solution politique
pour sortir de la crise.
La seule solution
viable est celle
des deux Etats.
J'ai porté ces messages
et cette exigence auprès
de l'ensemble
de mes interlocuteurs.
Pour ce qui est
de l'UNWRA,
vous le savez,
la France
n'avait pas
prévu
de versement avant le deuxième
trimestre.
Nous n'avons pas suspendu
nos versements,
contrairement
à un certain nombre
de pays occidentaux.
Nous nous appuierons
sur l'audit indépendant
des Nations Unies,
qui devra nous garantir
de la véracité
de ce qu'il s'est passé
et nous donner
des garanties pour l'avenir
pour que ces financements
puissent
être encore donnés par la France.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Bertrand Petit.
- Bertrand Petit:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le Premier
ministre, remonté
et très en colère,
c'est l'état d'esprit
des milliers de sinistrés
des inondations.
Malgré les visites
ministérielles
et les promesses,
ils ont le sentiment
que rien n'avance.
Il y a urgence à les indemniser.
Ils sont encore très nombreux
à attendre
le passage de l'expert
ou son rapport.
Trop d'incertitudes
concernant la mise en oeuvre
du fonds Barnier
et les conditions
de rachat
pour ceux d'entre
eux qui savent
qu'ils ne regagneront jamais
leur maison.
Le temps presse.
Il y a urgence à mobiliser
des aides immédiates
pour permettre
aux sinistrés de supporter
les biens sinistrés.
Il y a une urgence aussi
pour le paiement
de la taxe
foncière
pour ceux qui ne retourneront pas
encore
dans leur domicile
pour de très longs mois.
Dans toute la vallée
industrielle
de mon département,
des familles
ont tout perdu.
La réponse de l'Etat
doit être forte et rapide.
Dans ces communes,
les sinistrés déplorent
l'absence significative
de travaux de curage,
de lavage et d'enlèvement
des embâcles
des cours d'eau.
Les collectivités
sont au rendez-vous,
mais elles font avec leurs moyens.
A situation
exceptionnelle,
mesures exceptionnelles.
Quelles sont-elles?
Urgence à renforcer
et à moderniser
les parcs des pompes
vieillissantes
pour l'évacuation à la mer.
Certaines zones
de mon département
sont embrasées depuis des années.
Mes courriers sont restés
sans réponse,
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
Urgence à prendre
en charge les franchises
des artisans
et des commerçants sinistrés.
Vous en avez acté
le principe,
lors de votre déplacement.
J'ai cru comprendre
que cela n'était
plus d'actualité.
Qu'en est-il?
Au moment
où vous vous apprêtez
à revenir
dans mon département,
je peux vous assurer
que la colère
est particulièrement palpable.
En dépit de certaines
déclarations, rien n'est réglé.
Le temps des promesses est révolu.
Nos habitants attendent des actes.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
nous avons installé
il y a 15 jours
un comité
ministériel de suivi
qui se réunit tous les 15 jours.
Le décret de curage
a été publié
au Journal officiel.
Le 2 février,
le décret sur la prise
en charge du fonds
Barnier a été mis
en place.
Le jour de sa nomination,
le Premier ministre s'est rendu
sur place et il a annoncé
des aides.
Les modalités ont été annoncées
la semaine dernière
et elles correspondent
aux engagements pris,
à hauteur
de 15.000 euros,
pour ces sociétés.
Le président de la République
a déjà débloqué plusieurs millions
d'euros et ils ont permis
d'engager
des travaux sur les pompes.
Que ce soit sur l'enlèvement
des embâcles
ou sur les autres
canaux, je comprends
la colère,
mais je n'accepte pas
que vous disiez
que rien n'a été fait.
Les collectivités
locales et les élus
se mobilisent.
Si les solutions
miracles existent,
nous le saurions.
Trois missions
ont été conduites:
une pour regarder
ce que les Hollandais
et les Belges ont fait...
Pour lutter face
à ce type de phénomène,
penser qu'il faut
simplement monter
des digues ou installer
des pompes,
c'est ne pas comprendre
la nécessité
d'un plan de résilience
pour lutter
contre les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique.
Il nous faut un plan
sur la durée
pour savoir
ce que nous devons faire.
Nous aurons
les conclusions de ce plan
à la fin du mois de mars.
Les modalités
pour le fond Barnier
ont été précisées.
Des éléments
le seront à nouveau,
par la préfecture
du Pas-de-Calais
dans les jours qui viennent.
Le Premier ministre
aura l'occasion,
demain, à l'occasion
de sa deuxième visite
sur place en moins d'un mois,
de préciser
et de rappeler à nouveau
la mobilisation
de l'Etat.
Mettez-vous
dans le camp
de ceux qui proposent
des solutions
et de ceux qui font
en sorte
d'être aux côtés des sinistrés.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup,
monsieur le ministre.
Monsieur le ministre...
Monsieur le ministre,
vous êtes à 2 minutes
et 20 secondes.
Je vous invite à respecter.
Vous aviez aussi
débordé de 10 secondes,
monsieur le député.
Revenons sur nos deux minutes!
La parole est à madame
Caroline Yadan.
- Caroline Yadan:
Madame la présidente,
ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Stéphane Séjourné.
"Ramenez-les à la maison
maintenant."
Depuis le 7
octobre 2023,
nous avons entendu
ce cri de douleur
des familles déchirées,
mais si dignes,
qui n'ont plus de larmes,
dont les proches
ont été kidnappés
et qui sont parfois confrontées
aux mensonges que des porteurs
de haine édifiaient.
Depuis le 7
octobre 2023,
nous avons observé
les visages
de ceux qui ont été
arrachés
à leur famille à l'aube d'une
matinée sanglante,
au cours de laquelle
des barbares génocidaires
ont agi.
Etre otage à Gaza,
c'est être privé
de la lumière
de soleil,
c'est être prisonnier
de centaines
de kilomètres
de tunnels construits
par le Hamas
pour entreposer des armes
de guerre destinées
à tuer femmes
et enfants en Israël.
Etre otage à Gaza,
c'est être privé
de médicaments dont on a besoin
et attendre l'intervention
de la Croix-Rouge en vain.
Etre otage à Gaza,
c'est se dire
chaque jour que c'est peut-être
le dernier.
C'est être privé
de nourriture, de parole,
de sommeil.
C'est être insulté,
humilié et torturé
par des terroristes
islamistes endoctrinés
à la haine des juifs
dès le berceau.
Etre otage à Gaza,
c'est avoir un an
et avoir passé le quart
de sa vie privée
de liberté.
Etre otage à Gaza,
c'est aussi
dans l'obscurité
de l'incertitude,
garder la foi et l'espoir
d'être libéré.
Monsieur le ministre,
en ce jour
où un hommage
national a été rendu
aux victimes du massacre
du 7 octobre,
quel moyen la France
déploie-t-elle
pour venir en aide
aux 136 otages,
dont 3 Français,
encore aux mains
du Hamas?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, ma chère collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Séjourné.
- Stéphane Séjourné:
Merci, madame
la députée.
Comme je le disais,
je rentre d'Israël
où j'étais lundi,
à l'occasion d'une tournée
dans la région,
et j'ai rencontré
les familles
de nos compatriotes
encore otages
des terroristes du Hamas.
J'ai vu leur douleur.
Vos mots sont touchants.
Je pense que nous partageons
leur peine.
Après l'hommage
rendu ce matin
par la France à ses 42
enfants morts
en Israël,
lors de cette attaque barbare,
le président
de la République et moi-même
avons de nouveau
vu les familles
des otages.
Comme le président
de la République
l'a dit, ce matin,
une nouvelle fois,
comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire directement,
comme je l'ai
réaffirmé directement
à mes interlocuteurs,
la libération
de tous les otages,
sans aucune condition,
demeure la priorité de la France.
Je veux aussi dire
que nous agissons
sur le terrain
diplomatique,
avec nos partenaires
les plus engagés
dans cet effort.
Evidemment, Israël et le Qatar.
Mais aussi la Jordanie
et l'Egypte.
Nous agissons également
sur le terrain opérationnel,
où nous avons mené une opération
extrêmement complexe
pour fournir des médicaments
aux otages retenus
dans la bande de Gaza.
En cette journée
d'hommage, je tiens
à réaffirmer que la libération
des otages français
à Gaza fait aujourd'hui l'objet
d'une mobilisation entière
et totale des services de l'Etat.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Damien Maudet.
- Damien Maudet:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre
de la Santé.
Quand il y a des morts,
on ne fait
pas remonter l'info aux autorités.
Si ça
ne fait pas trop de bruit,
on cache l'information
sous le tapis.
Voilà ce que l'on me dit.
A Limoges, ce week-end,
il y a eu 90 personnes
aux urgences.
Cela veut dire
qu'il y en avait 70
dans les couloirs.
A Strasbourg,
le taux d'occupation des lits
est à 190%.
Ils ont installé
des lits sur le parking.
Partout, des patients
sont à l'agonie.
A Necker, un médecin alerte:
un enfant meurt tous les mois,
faute de pouvoir
être opéré.
Alors qu'un médecin
déplorait un manque
de moyens, ce soir-là,
le jeune Lucas 25 ans,
25 ans, est décédé
de septicémie,
après une nuit dans un couloir.
Les drames se multiplient.
"Tu casses, tu répares.
Tu salis, tu nettoies",
assène le Premier ministre.
Quand est-ce que cela
s'applique
pour vous?
Quand allez-vous
réparer
ce que vous avez détruit?
Si on en est là,
c'est de votre faute!
Depuis 2017,
vous avez supprimé
des centaines de lits
d'hospitalisation!
Le nombre de soignants
vacants est passé
à 60.000.
Le gouvernement
casse et il continue
de casser.
En octobre, vous avez passé
par 49.3 4 milliards d'économies
sur le dos des soignants.
Vous proposez
de faire payer
encore plus cher
l'accès à la santé!
Des gens peuvent
décéder seuls
sur les brancards,
faute de prise
en charge de personnel.
Combien de burn-out?
Combien de services
fermés et combien
de drames avant que
vous ne réagissiez?
- Catherine Vautrin:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
chacun le sait,
dans notre pays,
52.000 personnes passent
chaque jour dans les services
des urgences,
dont 10.000 enfants.
C'est la réalité
de ce que nous vivons
au quotidien,
avec des femmes
et des hommes
qui sont particulièrement
mobilisés, et je veux parler
des équipes soignantes.
Pour autant,
vous l'avez dit,
chaque mort
est évidemment un drame.
L'engagement du gouvernement
est extrêmement concret.
Je voudrais le remettre en avant.
Pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière,
dans cet hémicycle,
le Premier ministre
est revenu
sur le service d'accès
aux soins.
Nous avons actuellement
une soixantaine
de services
d'accès aux soins
dans notre pays
qui réunissent les libéraux
et les professionnels
hospitaliers.
L'objectif, c'est que,
d'ici l'été,
nous ayons
des services d'accès
aux soins dans chacun
des départements.
Un service
d'accès aux soins
dans chaque département,
c'est la certitude
d'avoir une réponse
médicalisée en fonction
des besoins de chacun
de ces patients.
Parallèlement à cela,
dès le mois
de janvier 2024,
le gouvernement a mis
en place une augmentation
des rémunérations
pour les gardes
et pour les travaux
des week-ends.
C'était attendu
et c'est aujourd'hui fait.
Ce que nous avons également
fait,
et que je voudrais
rappeler,
c'est le Ségur,
qui a permis l'accompagnement
financier des personnels.
Il reste à mettre
en place, et je m'y
suis engagée,
le Ségur engagement
qui répondra aux demandes.
C'est l'engagement
du gouvernement.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, madame
la ministre.
Une seconde.
- Damien Maudet:
Vous n'avez convaincu personne...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Une seconde.
La parole est à monsieur
Aurélien Taché.
- Aurélien Taché:
Monsieur le ministre
des Affaires étrangères,
depuis l'annonce
du président
Macky Sall du report
des élections,
le Sénégal est au bord
du chaos.
Depuis un an,
il a laissé planer
le doute sur sa volonté
de briguer
un troisième
mandat,
alors que c'est illégal.
Il a renoncé, face à la colère.
Ensuite, son principal opposant
a été déclaré inéligible,
après avoir insulté
un de ses ministres.
Sentant un risque
contre lui,
Macky Sall
est alors passé en force.
Il a éliminé tous les candidats
légalement désignés et,
au-delà de son contenu
antidémocratique,
vous avez vu
comme moi
dans quelles conditions
cette loi
a été adoptée,
alors que la police
a fait évacuer l'Assemblée.
Mirabeau avait dit:
"Nous sommes ici
par la volonté
du peuple
et nous n'en sortirons
que par la force
des baïonnettes."
C'est exactement
ce qui est arrivé
aux Sénégalais.
Face à cela,
la France, patrie
de la démocratie et grande
amie du Sénégal,
ne peut rester silencieuse.
Le président Macron
avait semé le trouble
sur sa position,
mais le doute n'est désormais
plus permis.
Je crois connaître
votre engagement,
monsieur le ministre,
mais condamnez-vous clairement
le coup d'Etat
institutionnel au Sénégal?
Appelez-vous au maintien
des élections?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Stéphane Séjourné.
- Stéphane Séjourné:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Monsieur le député,
nous suivons
la situation
au Sénégal
avec une très grande attention.
La décision de reporter de près
de 10 mois l'élection
présidentielle
et d'allonger d'autant
le mandat du président
plonge le Sénégal
dans une période d'incertitude
politique majeure.
C'est une situation
très préoccupante.
Nous appelons
les autorités à préserver
la longue et solide
tradition démocratique,
et à garantir l'ensemble
des libertés publiques.
Vous le savez,
le gouvernement doit répondre
aux aspirations légitimes
de sa population,
et notamment de sa jeunesse.
Nous partageons
également ce point
de vue.
Le peuple sénégalais doit pouvoir
choisir librement
ses dirigeants,
conformément aux règles
de l'état de droit,
de la démocratie sénégalaise,
et nous appelons
les autorités à organiser
les élections
présidentielles
le plus rapidement
possible, conformément
à la constitution du Sénégal.
C'est ce que les pays
d'Afrique de l'Ouest
ont rappelé, hier.
C'est ce que je veux
dire également, ici.
Nous nous engagerons
avec tous les acteurs,
les responsables
de la société civile,
les oppositions
et le parti présidentiel
dans cette voie.
Le Sénégal doit
rester démocratique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
- Aurélien Taché:
allez-y, vous, monsieur
le ministre.
N'envoyez pas vos assistants.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Cyrille Isaac-Sibille.
- Cyrille Isaac-Sibille:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
En juillet dernier,
Elisabeth Borne
m'a confié une mission
sur des substances chimiques
créées par l'homme
et utilisées
depuis plus de 70 ans
par les industriels.
Les "polluants éternels".
C'est une substance
qui résiste à l'eau,
aux graisses
et est difficilement dégradable.
Cela pose un gros problème
de santé publique,
avec entre autres
un problème d'infertilité
et de cancer.
Par rapport à ça,
nous avons affaire
à deux problèmes.
Nous devons réagir face
à la pollution historique,
en faisant cesser
les rejets
de cette substance.
Nous devons dépolluer
les eaux destinées
à la consommation humaine.
Nous devons restreindre
l'utilisation
de cette substance
en fonction
de son usage.
Nous savons que certaines
de ces substances
sont essentielles.
Certains médicaments
en sont constitués.
Nous devons aussi agir
pour la transition écologique.
D'autres de ces substances
sont futiles
et peuvent être interdites.
Dans quelle mesure la France
soutient-elle l'initiative
de cinq pays européens
de restriction
de l'ensemble
de la famille
de cette substance,
en fonction
des usages?
Quelle sera la position
de la France, vis-à-vis
du règlement européen
sur les emballages alimentaires,
actuellement discuté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
merci, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
Pour une durée de deux minutes!
- Christophe Béchu:
Merci, madame présidente.
Vous nous avez remis
ce rapport
il y a quelques jours,
qui s'articule
autour de deux grands axes:
mieux connaître,
pour mieux lutter.
Derrière l'appellation
de ces substances,
il y a des molécules
pour lesquelles
on connaît
les propriétés,
mais une immense majorité
de ces substances
nous est inconnue
en matière d'écologie,
d'établissement
de normes de rejet,
d'interaction
avec les monomères
et les polymères.
Nous devons faire
progresser la recherche
et la science.
Cela rejoint le plan
interministériel
en six axes
qui comportait une partie
sur l'Union Européenne.
En 2023, 6 pays
européens ont fait
en sorte que nous puissions
nous doter d'une réglementation
ambitieuse sur les emballages
qui posent
des principes d'interdiction.
Nous faisons partie
de cette coalition
et nous la soutenons.
Nous souhaitons pouvoir
agir en Européens
sur cette question.
Le premier rendez-vous,
il porte
sur la révision des règles
en matière d'emballage,
et en particulier
d'emballages alimentaires.
Le texte comprend
deux dimensions:
la volonté d'interdire
au niveau européen
le bisphénol A.
Il est interdit
en France, depuis 2015.
Le deuxième consiste
à interdire
ces substances
dans les emballages alimentaires.
Nous soutenons cette position.
La France souhaite que cette règle
s'applique partout
en Europe.
Comptez
sur notre mobilisation
et sur le fait que,
dans ces 18 recommandations,
nous sommes d'ores
et déjà
en train de regarder
celle que nous allons pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre
dans quelques mois.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Louis Bricout.
- Jean-Louis Bricout:
Merci, madame
la présidente.
Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Ecologie.
Face aux enjeux
climatiques,
avec la fin annoncée
de la commercialisation
des véhicules thermiques,
d'ici 2035,
il nous faut motiver
nos concitoyens
à passer à l'électrique.
Les pouvoirs publics
sont au rendez-vous,
avec le bonus
écologique, la prime
à la conversion
ou le leasing social.
Concernant
le rechargement,
c'est une autre affaire.
On est loin d'un plan
à coût dérisoire.
Si vous rechargez
au domicile,
tout va bien.
Avec des trajets longs,
qui vous forcent
à l'itinérance,
le prix des rechargements laisse
place à de mauvaises surprises.
On est loin des conditions
de concurrence constatées
dans les traditionnelles
stations-service.
Pas ou peu
d'affichage des prix
aux bornes,
pas ou peu d'affichage
sur les routes,
pas ou peu d'accès
par carte bancaire.
Pas de sites
comparatifs des tarifs.
Des frais de stationnement
et des frais
à la minute
qui peuvent s'ajouter
aux frais d'énergie.
S'ajoute aussi
une obligation de souscrire
à un ou plusieurs
abonnements pour obtenir
un tarif préférentiel.
L'UFC-Que choisir
donne l'exemple
du rechargement d'une
voiture citadine,
à Lyon.
Le coût peut varier
de 7,35 euros
à plus de 12 euros,
en fonction de l'utilisateur.
Cela peut décourager
les volontés d'acquérir
un véhicule propre.
Je vais soumettre
une proposition
de loi visant à tracer
les conditions
d'une réelle concurrence.
Etes-vous prêt
à accueillir favorablement
nos propositions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu:
Monsieur le député,
merci pour votre question.
Monsieur le député
Bricout, je souhaite
que l'attention
que vous portez
à ce sujet paie.
Nous allons regarder
comment l'aménagement
de notre territoire
permettra
à tous nos concitoyens
d'accéder
à cette technologie.
Vous avez parlé du souhait
de l'acquisition.
Nous sommes en train
de connaître
un succès avec le leasing social.
Nous avons dépassé
les 35.000 réservations
en termes de leasing.
Votre sujet porte sur les bornes.
Non seulement,
j'accueille de façon
tout à fait favorable
la perspective
que vous lancez
sur cette question,
mais j'accueille
avec impatience
les propositions
que vous nous ferez.
J'attends le rapport
de l'Autorité
de la concurrence,
qui s'est auto-saisie
de toutes les questions
que vous venez
de soulever
sur les difficultés d'accès,
les écarts de prix,
les déficits d'information.
On a un plan
de déploiement des bornes
de recharge qui nous a permis
de dépasser
les 100.000 bornes au mois de mai.
On a un règlement
européen
que nous allons renforcer.
Il y a, en parallèle,
les pratiques
que vous décrivez
et sur lesquelles
le rapport de l'Autorité
de la concurrence
et les propositions
que nous ferons,
avec tout cela,
nous aurons matière
à compléter les trous
dans la raquette.
- Jean-Louis Bricout:
Merci
de votre réponse.
Il faut effectivement
aller vite,
si on ne veut pas décourager
nos usagers.
- Olivier Marleix:
Monsieur le Premier ministre,
pour la troisième
semaine consécutive,
Mayotte est paralysée
par la manifestation
de la société
civile qui bloque
les voies de circulation.
La cause de cette grave
crise est l'explosion
de l'insécurité
et l'amplification
de l'immigration
clandestine,
depuis l'arrêt
de l'opération
qui était censée
restaurer l'état
de droit.
La cause est également
l'absence
de réponse aux alertes
des élus de Mayotte,
dont la demande
de réunion d'urgence
avec le gouvernement
est restée
sans suite.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la rue
qui s'exprime.
Ils craignent
que Mayotte devienne
le Lampedusa indien
et que l'île
soit sous la coupe des gangs.
Quand votre gouvernement
prendra-t-il
des mesures à la hauteur
pour mettre
un terme aux flux
migratoires venus
des Comores et de la corne
de l'Afrique?
Quand allez-vous
mobiliser des moyens
de la Marine
nationale
pour être en mesure
de stopper ces flux?
Quand allez-vous présenter
cette loi Mayotte,
que vous avez annoncée
et qui devait
être transmise
aux élus de Mayotte,
dès le mois de février?
Quand allez-vous
relancer l'opération
sur l'île, pour reconquérir
les territoires perdus
de la République, à Mayotte?
Je pense aux mesures
qui ont été censurées
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
Voilà les questions
que se posent
les habitants de Mayotte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le président.
La parole est à monsieur
le Premier ministre.
- Gabriel Attal:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Monsieur le président
Olivier Marleix,
je le dis d'emblée,
la situation à Mayotte
et ce que vivent les habitants
est totalement insupportable.
Si cette situation
était vécue
dans un département
de l'Hexagone,
on en entendrait
parler matin, midi
et soir.
Cette situation,
vous l'avez dit,
elle indigne les élus locaux,
les parlementaires.
Vous avez cité les députés.
Ils sont mobilisés
sur cette question.
Les sénateurs
le sont actuellement,
et ils m'ont interrogé,
la semaine dernière,
sur ce sujet.
La première priorité,
c'est de rétablir l'ordre public
et de permettre
la reprise des activités.
Sous l'autorité du préfet
et du procureur
de la République,
les forces de l'ordre luttent
contre les violences
urbaines et interpellent
le plus grand nombre
possible de délinquants,
et je veux saluer leur engagement.
Nous devons aussi entendre
les revendications
des manifestants,
qui manifestent face
à une situation insupportable.
Pour cela, il faut
pouvoir se parler.
J'invite les collectifs
à saisir
les invitations
des élus à échanger.
Les manifestants
et les élus demandent
le retour à l'ordre.
Ils demandent
l'évacuation du camp
du stade.
J'avais annoncé une opération
de démantèlement
de ce camp de Cavani.
L'opération a bel et bien démarré.
Il reste encore des personnes
présentes
et je demande une accélération
de l'opération d'évacuation.
Je le dis très clairement,
le démantèlement
de ce camp est en cours
et sera mené
à son terme.
Le gouvernement agit
aussi sur les causes
de cette situation.
Notre premier objectif,
c'est de prévenir
les arrivées
irrégulières à Mayotte,
en luttant contre les filières
d'immigration illégale.
Nous avons considérablement
renforcé
les moyens pour lutter
contre ces filières.
Nous en avons démantelé
un certain nombre.
Des condamnations
ont eu lieu
et elles ont donné des peines
de prison lourdes.
J'ai conscience que le Conseil
constitutionnel
a censuré certaines mesures
que j'avais présentées.
Dans le cadre
de la future loi Mayotte,
il faut remettre
tout cela sur la table
et regarder comment
ces mesures pourraient
être adoptées et validées
par le Conseil constitutionnel,
pour être plus efficaces.
Nous devons
être plus efficaces aussi
pour expulser rapidement
les étrangers
sans titre, y compris
les ressortissants
de pays africains.
Les déboutés de l'asile font
systématiquement l'objet
de mesures d'éloignement.
Plusieurs départs
sont prévus,
cette semaine
et la semaine prochaine.
Je souhaite que l'on puisse
accélérer l'ensemble
ces mesures.
Tout cela sera
recensé dans le cadre
du plan sur l'immigration.
Il faut donner
les moyens à Mayotte
de mieux lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière
et sur la sécurité.
Il faut donner
à Mayotte les moyens
de son développement
sur le long terme.
C'est l'objectif
du projet de loi dédié
à Mayotte,
que le gouvernement présentera
après en avoir débattu
avec les élus.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci, monsieur
le ministre.
- Olivier Marleix:
Cela fait
au moins sept ans
que notre collègue
vous alerte, mois après mois.
Les résultats ne sont pas là.
Il faut mobiliser des moyens
de la Marine nationale
pour enfin défendre Mayotte.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame
la présidente Isabelle Rauch.
- Isabelle Rauch:
Merci, madame la présidente.
Ma question s'adresse
à la ministre
de la Culture.
Une étape historique
a été franchie,
la semaine dernière,
en matière d'encadrement
de l'intelligence artificielle.
Les 27 Etats-membres
de l'Union Européenne
ont voté sur la première
réglementation mondiale
sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Il faut se féliciter
de l'aboutissement
de ce texte à l'unanimité.
Ce vote rappelle aussi
le rôle déterminant
de l'Europe
pour répondre aux défis
de notre temps.
J'aimerais attirer
votre attention
sur la manière
dont l'IA bouleverse
le monde de la culture,
pour nos acteurs,
nos journalistes et nos créateurs.
L'intelligence
artificielle peut
être un formidable
outil,
mais on nous alerte
depuis longtemps
sur les risques
d'une intelligence
artificielle pas suffisamment
encadrée.
Aujourd'hui, les intelligences
artificielles génératives peuvent
collecter des articles
et des oeuvres
sans prévenir
leurs auteurs
et sans les rémunérer.
Nous parlons aussi
des données personnelles.
Les intelligences
artificielles
sont capables
de reproduire l'apparence
ou la voix d'acteurs
parfois décédés.
La capacité de générer
des oeuvres artificielles
va changer notre définition
d'une oeuvre d'art.
Le texte européen apporte
des réponses concrètes.
Il permet de bloquer
les utilisations abusives
et d'encourager
les utilisations volontaires.
L'intelligence artificielle
a un vrai rôle
à jouer,
mais pour que la France
puisse prendre le tournant
de l'intelligence artificielle,
nous devons nous sentir
en confiance.
La protection est cruciale.
Pouvez-vous nous assurer
que la mise en oeuvre
du règlement européen
sur l'intelligence artificielle
respectera l'équilibre
du texte et permettra
de créer un climat
de confiance?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
Merci beaucoup.
La parole est à madame
Rachida Dati.
- Rachida Dati:
Madame la présidente,
madame la députée,
l'adoption à l'unanimité,
le 2 février
dernier, de l'un
des tout premiers
textes permettant
de donner un cadre sûr
au développement
de l'intelligence
artificielle
est une vraie avancée.
C'est même une première.
La production
du droit d'auteur
et du droit voisin
est le fondement
de notre modèle
de soutien aux créateurs
et à la diversité de la création.
Je sais que c'est une de
vos préoccupations.
Nous en avons discuté.
L'intelligence
artificielle générative
se nourrit de très nombreuses
oeuvres protégées
par le droit d'auteur.
C'est pour cela qu'avec
votre soutien,
le gouvernement
était très attentif
à ce respect des droits
des créateurs
et du respect du secret
des affaires.
Et ce, afin de permettre
l'innovation.
Je sais
que notre conviction
commune est qu'il est vain
d'opposer innovation
et droits d'auteur.
Le texte adopté
permet d'adopter
un équilibre
et nous veillerons
à ce qu'il soit respecté.
Cette première
étape
n'épuise pas
toutes les questions
que nous nous posons.
Je sais pouvoir compter
sur le Conseil supérieur
de la propriété littéraire,
et artistique,
qui est une instance
placée auprès
de mon ministère,
pour accompagner
une plus large réflexion
sur l'application
et la mise en oeuvre du respect
de cet équilibre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est suspendue.